[Music]
rob is with us in spokane
hi rob welcome to the show hi guys how
are you today
better than we deserve what's up um
i am calling um because i'm in debt and
i'm trying to figure out the best way to
get out of it um i've been looking at a
couple different options
um and i've made a budget for myself and
everything like that and basically what
i found out is
i can either go ahead and
and you know work on making these
payments and all these separate
locations all at once
and you know and throw myself in a real
financial pickle for the foreseeable
future or i was wondering if
a debt consolidation option would be the
better way to go so i have all that debt
in one place
and i can stress out
or be a little less stressed about it
going forward
so you want it you want to stay in that
longer
yeah but did you hear what he said
oh wait maybe i didn't what did you say
i said so you want to stay in debt
longer
oh no i do not well that's the way the
payment goes down
okay right i was i was not aware of that
well i mean from what
if you're paying i mean what's the total
of all the payments on all the
how many different debts do you have i
have
about five different debts um each or
all of them totaling to be about uh
twelve thousand dollars
okay and what is the monthly payments
total up to be on that twelve thousand
dollars
uh just about fifteen hundred
okay and so you would be done in under a
year
so what is your income uh just about two
thousand dollars a month
oh okay well that's why 1500 is killing
you then right
yeah okay and so what are these debts on
what kind of debt is it um it's uh
my car um is is the majority of it
um and then several credit cards which
uh maybe
a young man decided it would be a good
idea to max them out and then i realized
that that is a bad idea i'll hear you
okay
so what do you owe on your car and
what's your car payment
uh my car payment is uh eight thousand
dollars and i pay just about three
hundred dollars a month on it
okay it's not the majority of the 1500
then
oh yeah no it's uh it's what is the
other pay what are the other payments on
the 1500 did you include like your rent
in that number
yes correct my rent isn't that number no
no no no no no no okay you said
12 000 worth of debt right
the payments on that are 300 for the car
which is 8 000 of the 12. the other 4
000 what are the payments on the other 4
000 which are credit cards right
oh yes uh so for my credit cards those
are each about 100
a month um so my outgoing debt 700 bucks
a month
i rent 700 bucks a month what do you do
for a living
um i am a automotive technician
at a local car garage here okay how old
are you
i am 22 tomorrow okay good for you
okay here's the math
if you didn't have a car payment you'd
be fine if your income went up one
thousand dollars a month
you'd be fine and the stress would be
gone right
okay so your budget is every dollar that
you have coming in
is assigned to something we're assigning
300
to the car 100 bucks a piece of the
credit cards and then we're going to
start paying them off
so if you were to say i have 12 000
worth of debt and i'm gonna put a
thousand dollars on debt and i'm gonna
live on a thousand
you'd be done in one year right correct
let's do that oh by the way let's take
an extra job
that makes a thousand dollars a month
and let's get out of that even faster
okay yeah rob what you don't want to do
consolidating as they said it's going to
lengthen the period of indebtedness
meaning
the reason your payment goes down in the
consolidation is that they're
extending how long you're going to be in
debt
so it's it's this terrible math man it
really is
it is terrible it doesn't work and
people fall for it all the time
you've got four debts three credit cards
and a car
you can manage that okay and so us
talking about the debt snowball approach
smallest to biggest
because getting out of debt is not about
math or interest rate it's about
momentum
and so please do not consolidate these
leave these things individually and
attack them smallest to biggest
yeah and so if you say i'm going to pay
the minimum payments plus
money up to 1 000 per month
total so the minimum payments let's call
them 700 okay the three credit cards
are four credit cards at 100 bucks plus
300 car are you with me
yes that's 700 so if we say okay the
other 300 to get to a thousand
because i i still want to be done in a
year so 12 divided by a thousand is
one thousand dollars per month right so
twelve thousand divided by twelve months
is one thousand dollars per month
plus or minus some interest but we're
gonna be real close on that so
if you said i'm gonna put a thousand
dollars a month on my debt or more
then i'm gonna put three hundred dollars
extra on the smallest credit card how
much do you owe on the smallest credit
card
uh 500 okay so it's going to be done in
one month
right now it's gone yeah now we've got
three credit cards what's the next
smallest one
uh 500 as well they're about tight okay
another month and a half that one's
going to be gone
what you seeing how this is working yeah
yeah and you're cutting them up of
course
time to have plastic surgery and then
you're going to work your way right
through this so jump on
every dollar at everydollar.com and
download the budgeting
app and it'll show you how to build your
budget out and get that going
i'm going to send you a copy of the book
the total money makeover to show you
exactly how
to do the things we're talking about
here you can do this
it's going to work for you you really
can and i want everyone else out there
to keep your eyes open now
because around in the next six months
you're going gonna start to get all
these goofy mailers
in the mail they're gonna show you how
they can help you and
listen we know how to count fuzzy math
is never becomes clear
right it's clearly a trap so work a plan
that works